[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوي
تقارب من تركيا المصريين احوال تطبيعي
العلاقات واردوغان يؤكد على علاقات اوسع
مع القاهره في المستقبل
وحده جديده لشؤون الاطفال في النيابه
العامه السعوديه ضوابط طول الرعايه
والحمايه والترفيه
رابعه ايضا
رابعه راكب مشروع تطوير قلعه عارف
التاريخيه في حائل يعود عمرها الى اكثر من
200 عام
وثانيا من كاس العالم 2022 في قطر ايران
في مواجهه الانجليزي والسنغال تلتقي
هولندا
صفحه جديده في العلاقات بين مصر وتركيا
بعد لقاء الرئيسين عبد الفتاح السيسي ورجب
طيب اردوغان في الدوحه رئاسه المصريه كادت
انه تم التاكيد المتبادل على عنق الروابط
التاريخيه بين مصر والتركيا وتم التوافق
على ان يكون هذا اللقاء بدايه لتطوير
العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
من جهته على الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان على مصافحه الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي له في قطر مؤكدا بانها كانت
الخطوه الاولى نحو التطبيعه وتاسيس السلام
مع مصر
وبحسب وسائل الاعلام تركيا قرار اردوغان
انه يريد ان تكون الاجتماعات مع مصر على
مستوى اعلى واستئناف محادثات التطبيق
واضاف اردوغان بان الطلب الوحيد لتركيا من
مصر وتغيير في الموقف بشان ثروات شرق
البحر المتوسط
من اسطنبول المحلل السياسي طه عوده اوغلو
سيد طه مرحبا بك يعني اولا
مصافحه المونديال في قطر هل يمكن بالفعل
ان تكون البدايه الحقيقيه
لتطبيق كامل في العلاقات بين مصر
وانقره بالرغم من كل الملفات الخلافيه بين
البلدين
يا استاذ خالد
اختراق كبير في العلاقات التركيه المصريه
وخاصه تحدثنا كثيرا خلال الاشهر الاخيره
الماضيه عن ان العلاقات التركيه المصريه
والتطبيعه العلاقات تفسير بطئ حتى لن
تنتقل بشكل كامل الى المستوى السياسي ان
يصل الامر ان يلتقي الزعيمين التركي
والمصري همم في يعني مونديال قطر وفي هذه
اللعبه القدم اعتقد هذه خطوه مهمه
وايجابيه كما وصفها الجانب التركي والرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ايضا تتبعنا
التصريحات التركيه وخاصه التي صدرت من
رئيس اردوغان خلال اسابيع الاخيره على
الرغم انه هناك تصريحات صد رد قبل ان
تتذكر قبل اسبوعين من سامح شكري وزير
الخارجيه المصري تحدث عن هناك
المباحثات الاستكشافيه ما بين البلدين لكن
الرئيس اردوغان اكد مرارا بانه ضروره
تفعيل العلا واعاده العلاقات ما بين
البلدين وركز على ان هناك علاقات اخويه ما
بين الشعب المصري والتركي لذا انا تصور
اعتقد الايام المقبله ولسابيع المقبله
ممكن نشهد هناك تطور اعلى ممكن على سبيل
المثال نشاهد او نتابع جميعا لقاء يجمع
وزير خارجيه همم التركي مع وزير الخارجيه
المصري خلال الاسابيع المقبله واتبعه ايضا
حاليا حاجز الذي كان هو المفروض همم خلال
فتره الاخيره الماضيه واقصد اللقاء الكبار
يعني ما بين الزعيمين اعتقد هذا الحديث تم
اختراقه ممكن ان يكون لقاء كبير في
القاهره ما بين الرئيس اردوغان والرئيس
السيسي اردوغان في تصريحاته قال بان الطلب
الوحيد لتركيا من مصر هو تغيير في الموقف
بشان ثروات شرق البحر المتوسط
هذا الموقف وهذا التصريح هل يعني ان هناك
تقدم في الملفات الاخرى الخلافيه يعني
مثلا ملف الاخوان كنقطه خلاف مركزيه كانت
بين البلدين مصر
مازالت الى وقت قريب تتشكك ربما في موقف
تركيا التي ترى بانها تقدم قدما وتاخر
اخرى فبالتالي في هذا الملف هل يمكن
لتركيا ان تتجاوب وتغلق جميع الابواب
الاعلاميه والمنافذ السياسيه للاخوان
المسلمين في قطر في تركيا عفوا
جنى نعم انا تصور اعتقد خلال الفتره
الاخيره الماضيه تابعنا عبر قناتكم تحدثنا
هنا عن ان موضوع الاخوان هو موضوع نعم
انشائك ولكن انا تصوري تم تجاوزه واعتقد
ان تركيا هي متوافقه مع الجانب المصري قبل
فتره هناك كانت بعض التصريحات وبعض
الاصوات التي علت هنا في الداخل التركي من
بعض المصريين تم اعتقال عدد كبير منهم
والان حاليا هناك صديق بشكل كامل على اي
همم
قريبه من الاخوان تريد العمل بشكل سياسي
في الداخل همم تركيا ولكن اعتقد الملف
الشائع هو كان الملف الليبي الى حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني قبل فتره ان انا قبل هذا
اللقاء هناك مباحثات كانت مستمره ما بين
همم الطرفين على الرغم ان كان الوصول الى
توافق نوعا وتفاهمات في حد ما هو خاصه
اللقاءات التي جمعت الليبيين هنا في
اسطنبول وفي انقره وايضا في همم القاهره
قال هامل تحدثت عنها نعم هو موضوع شرقي
متوسط موضوع الغاز اعتقد حاليا هناك حاجه
ماسه ليس لتركيا ولكن للعالم برمتنا نحن
نتحدث عن ازمه حرب روسيه اوكرانيه
والجميله يحضر ما بعد هذه الحرب من هناك
ازمه في الدول الاوروبيه تركيا تحاول قدر
الامكان ان تتفاهم وهناك قناعه تامه لدى
الجانب التركي بان يعني من دون مصر ومن
دون يعني الدول الكميه بتلعبوا مصر في شقه
الاوسط هو الصعب همم الاهداف التي
ينضم الينا الان من القاهره ايضا عمرو
الشوبكي المستشار في مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه دكتور
عمرو اهلا بك همم في قراءهك لبيان الرئاسه
المصريه همم بعض قال بانه يعني بيان
دبلوماسي الى حد ما الذي قلبه انه تم
التاكيد على
المتبادل على عنق الروابط التاريخيه بين
مصر والتركيا هذا في اطار تعبير همم ربما
اا عن المصافحه الموندياليه اذا جاز لنا
وصفها بهذا شكل في قطر لكن الى اي مدى
بالفعل يمكن القول بانه هذه المصافحه هذا
البيان همم ازال حالا معينه من الخلافات
بين البلدين والتقدم في في مستوى هذه
العلاقه الى اي حد هذا الكلام صحيح
مساء الخير عليكم وعلى الساده المشاهدين
يعني همم بلا شك هي همم
مصافحه رفعت حواجز كثيره يعني همم هذه
المصافحه لو كانت همم فقط في دلالاتها
البروتوكليه او في وجودها في المونديال
همم لكنت همم يعني ربما قد تمت منذ فترات
سابقه همم اهميتها انه جانب كبير من
الحواجز التي اعاقت تطور العلاقات المصريه
التركيه قد تم تجاوزه وهذا في احد ذاته
امر ايجابي بما اا يعني يمثلوا همم
الرئيسيين في نظام سياسي جمهوري قوامه
النظام الرئاسي سواء في تركيا بعد تعديل
الدستور او في مصر همم كذلك يعني منذ ربما
تاسيس الجمهوريه وبالتالي همم الفكره انه
يبقى انت تتم خطوات يقوم بها ال- اا كلا
الرئيسيين حتى لو كانت هذه الخطوه هي
مساله المصافحه فهذا في راي رفح حواجز
كثيره
ومعناها ايضا انه همم ان هناك ملفات
سياسيه همم سيتم مناقشتها بين البلدين
بشكل همم صحي وفي مناخ صحي كما اا اشار
الزميل من اسطنبول انه الجانب من المعضله
والاشكاليه الاساسيه اا في هذه العلاقات
هي انه كانت هناك قنوات تحريض سياسي همم
ضد همم مصر همم تقوم بها عناصر همم من
الاخوان او محسوبه عليها وهنا هذا الامر
لم يكن له علاقه بان تتباين الرؤى في
الملف الليبي او ان تتباين الرؤى حتى في
التعاطي مع تيارات الاسلام السياسي هذه
تباينات يعني موجوده في منطقه في عالمنا
العربي والاسلامي ولكن كان الخلاف على
يكون هناك منصات للتحقيق الكراهيه
والترويج للعمره
الاولويه الان في العلاقات بين البلدين في
تركيا كانت تصريحات اردوغان واضح قال بان
موضوع البحر المتوسط هو ماله الاولويه
يعني
في الملف الليبيه الطرفان يدعمران الطرفين
متصارعين ومتنافسين في في ليبيا مصر تعترض
على وجود مقاتلين ومرتزقه جانب همم وايضا
تركيا لها موقف في ليبيا واضح وصريح فب-
الى اي مدى بالفعل الملف اللي يمكن ان
يحصل فيه تقدم وتفاهم بين البلد دين همم
يعني طبعا بلا شك يعني انه انه انه انه
يكون هناك تعامل في ظل مناخ صحي هذا
يجعلنا يعني قادرين على التعامل بشكل
مباشر مع الملفات والقضايا الخلافات
العالقه وابرزها اا الملف الليبي هنا
ودوا اؤكد على مسالتين المساله الاولى انه
همم في لحظه من اللحظات كان هناك توافق
همم بين كل الدول العربيه مع الجانب
التركي على دعم حكومه ادبيبه يعني لم يكن
هناك طرف اا رفض هذه الحكومه حين تم
تكلفها
بالقيام بمهامها الان هناك بالفعل وجهات
نظر متباينه همم هناك دعم همم
لفتحي بشاره الذي كلف من قبل البرلمان وفي
نفس الوقت هناك حرص من الجانب المصري على
تقطع قنوات صاله مع الاطراف الاخرى
الموجوده في طرابلس حتى لو اختلفت مع
الحكومه وحتى لو رات انها حكومه تصريف على
المال ويجب التشكيل حكومه جديده الاداء
المصري طوال الفتره الماضيه في ليبيا كان
يقر بانه هناك اطراف همم ثلاثه لديها وجود
على الارض هناك همم طرابلس همم وما تمثله
الحكومه واعتراف اخرى وهناك همم
المشير حفتر وهناك رئيس البرلمان من هنا
انا اتصور انه همم الحفاظ على هذه
العلاقات بالاطراف الثلاثيه وانه حتى لو
كان هناك خلاف مع الجانب التركي على بعض
القضايا هذا حقيقي وموجود يجب التطرق اليه
ويجب فتح هذا الملف ويجب على كل سواء كان
مصر او تركيا ان يقر بانه لا يمكن اقصاء
اي من الاطراف الثلاثه من المشهد الليبي
ولابد من الى طاوله مفاوضات يكون خارجها
الميليشيات والجماعات المتطرفه والجماعات
الارهابيه في الخارج اي تفاوض معروف سيد
ماذا تريد تركيا تحديدا من مصر في ملف
البحر الابيض المتوسط الان والى اي مدى
يمكن ان تتنازل في الموقف الليبي مقابل
موقف ايضا مصري في هذا الملف
في البدايه تحدث لك عن الموقف في موضوع
المتوسط تعلم ان هناك علاقات متوتره ليست
بيئه الجديده قديمه جدا ما بين تركيا
واليونان هناك انقره تقول بانه هناك
محاولات يونانيه قبرصيه لاستبعاد تركيه عن
ثروه المتوسط تركيا خلال الفتره الاخيره
الماضيه هي حاولت كسر هذا الحاجز ونجح في
التقارب مع مصر خاصه تتحدث عن ان الاجانب
المصري والتركي كان هناك تفاهمات او تفاهم
للشرف القارئ لكل طرف من الاخر وحتى انقر
عملت عليه اكثر من مره من الممكن ان
تستفيد يعني من التعاون مع تركيا في شرق
المتوسط ايضا هناك كما شرتك موضوع الغاز
والطاقه هو مفيد لكلى البلدين خاصه في ظل
الازمات اقتصاديه تمر بها المنطقه في
الموضوع الليبي انا تصور اعتقد في الموضوع
الليبي القنوات الاستخباراتيه اقصى
استخبارات التركيه المصريه لعبه دور كبير
في التقارب خلال الفتره الاخيره الماضيه
تركيا قناه تماما وتفهمت الموقف التركي
وخاصه المتعلق بالامن القومي المصري كما
حدث الرئيس السيسي تذكر قبل عامين على
الخطا الخطوط الحمراء تركيا هي تعي تماما
وانقلت ما تريده فقط على مصالحها وخاصه
اتفاقيات التي ابرمتها في لم يكن هناك اي
ملامح لاتفاقيه كانت مساله تهدئه اعاده
الاوضاع لتشتعل على الارض مره اخرى خلال
الاسابيع القليله الماضيه وبالتالي ربما
اعود اليك وسريعا هنا الدكتور عمرو شوكي
همم الى اي مدى يمكن ان تتعامل ايضا مصر
في في الموقف في البحر المتوسط خاصه البعض
يفهم بانه تركيا قد تريد موقفا من مصر على
حساب العلاقات المصريه اليونانيه هل يمكن
ان تذهب في هذا الاتجاه سريع
يعني انا اعتقد انه امكانيه ان نجد حل في
ظل الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه والازمه
العالميه في مجال الطاقه يمكن ان نجد
حلولا تضم الجميع تضم الجانب التركي وتضم
الجانب اليوناني والا تكون العلاقات
استعاده العلاقات مع تركيا على حساب
الجانب اليوناني وهذا اعتقد انه اصبح يعني
خط عام حتى يعني الحديث عن اي اشتعال
للاوضاع في ليبيا هو نحن لم نعود الى
اوضاع 2018 ولا 2019 ولم يعد هناك طرف
يقول انه قادر على حسن الصراع بالقوه
المسلحه وحتى المحاوله التي كانت من عده
اشهر سرعان ما اكتشف الجميع انه لن يستطيع
طرف من مصراته مثلا ان يسيطر على طرابلس
بالقوه المسلحه ولن تستطيع طرابلس ان تلغي
الاطراف الاخرى وبالتالي الواقع يقول انه
يعني متقبل لفكره التوافقات والتفاهمات
لانه بعد خب السنوات الماضيه اكتشفنا انه
لا يمكن اقصاء طرف من اطراف اللعبه سواء
على المستوى الاقليمي او على مستوى اطراف
الصراع داخل ليبيا شكرا جزيلا لكم من
القاهره الدكتور عمرو الشوبكي المستشار في
مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه ومن اسطنبول الى المحلل
السياسي طه عوده
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
مصدره كويتيه تكشف عن خطه حكوميه لتوظيف
25,000 مواطن في القطاع الخاص خلال خمس
سنوات
اهلا بكم من جديد في الكويت فقط مجلس
الوزراء في جلسته المنعقده اليوم على
مشروع مرسوم العفو الخاص عن جرائم محدده
واشاره مركز التواصل الحكومي لانه الى ان
موافقه مجلس الوزراء استكمالا للمبادره
الاميريه بشان ملف العفو عن المواطنين
واعمالا لاحكام الماده الخامسه والسبعين
من الدستور
في الكويت ايضا ذكرت صحيفه القبا سن
الحكومه في البلاد تتجه الى العمل على
برنامج حكومي يبين فوائده ومزايا توظيف
الاعمال الوطنيه ضمن القطاع الخاص مقابل
القطاع العامه البرنامج
يهدف الى ضمانه دعم موظفي القطاع الخاص
لتحفيز المواطنين للبقاء في القطاع الخاص
وخلق فرص وظيفيه في المهن التي يتم العزوف
عنها في القطاع الخاص اضافه الى تحقيق هدف
ياتي ضمن عده خطوات وهو توظيف 25,000
مواطن كويتين في القطاع ليصلها عدده
العاملين في الى مئه في مواطن خلال خمس
سنوات
بدات الهيئه السعوديه للملكيه الفكريه
بالشراكه مع وزاره التعليم تنفيذ مشروع
ادراج موضوعات الملكيه الفكريه في المناهج
والمقررات الدراسيه في مراحل التعليم
العام الذي تسعى من خلاله الى تطوير القيم
اللازمه لتمكين الطلاب من مهارات التفكير
الابداعيه والابتكار اضافه الى تنميه
سلوكيات الحفاظ على الحقوق المعنويه
والماديه للمبدعين والتعزيز الوعي بقواعد
الملكيه الفكريه وضوابطها
من رياض ينضم الينا رئيس تنفيذي للهيئه
السعوديه للملكيه الفكريه الدكتور عبد
العزيز السويلم دكتور عبد العزيز حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه
اول ماذا يعني هذا المشروع
ادراج موضوع الملكيات الفكريه في المناهج
والمقررات الدراسيه كيف سيتم ذلك
ان المملكه تؤكد على ما بدات في رؤيتها في
20 30 الاستثمار الانسان والاستثمار رؤيه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يؤكد على ان يجب ان نبني الاجيال بحيث
انها تكون اجيال قادره على الابداع
والابتكار قادره على معرفه الحقوق حمايه
الحقوق وايضا الاحترام حقوق
هذا ما يعمل عليها هذه المشروع بالشراكه
مع الزملاء وزاره التعليم للتاكد عند
الطلاب والطالبات في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لديهم الحصيده الكافيه للبناء
على اذكار المبدعاتهم وايضا لمعرفه ما هي
الضوابط ومعايير وملوكيات الفكريه حتى
يكونوا في مصر امثالهم على مستوى العالم
الملكيه الفكريه في المناهج المقررات
الدراسيه يعني
يمكن احد يقول لك انه الطلاب مع هذه
الزيادات وضع الكثير من المواضيع مش
ناقصين مواضيع جديده جديده
جدا في البناء على همم يتم انتاجه كرامه
اذا ارادت المملكه العربيه السعوديه من
خلال رؤيه 2030 ان تبني على ابداعات
المواطنين والتكاراتهم حيث انها تتحول الى
منتجات قابله للاستثمار الصناعي يجب ان
يجب ان ننتج جيل يعرف معنى الابتكار يعرف
كيف يستطيع ان يحول افكاره الى منتجات
يعرف كيف يجعل هذه المنتجات الذات اكثر
تنموي اقتصادي على المستوى الوطني
وبالتالي تصبح قدره المملكه العربيه
السعوديه على ان تكون قدره ابداعيه
ابتكاريه منتجه المسارات العلوم والتقنيه
والتكرار وغيرهم المسارات الابداعيه هذا
سيحدث ايضا ان تكون المملكه في الدول
المتقدمه التي بنت على العقول اكثر
من خلال الشركه وزاره التعليم على التاكد
ان ابجديات ومبادئ
تنميه الافكار وحمايتها سيكون لها اثر
كبير جدا على ابنائه وبناتنا في المدارس
الاسلاميه اللغه العربيه العلوم
الايه القرانيه نعرف كيف يمكن ان عندما
نقتل التفسير لهذه الايات نشير الى
المراجع بشكل صحيح نعلم الطلاب عندما يرجع
من خلال ماده همم
الرقميه كيف يستطيع ان يرجع الى المواقع
الصحيح ويشير الى هذه المواقع بشكل سليم
ههه كيف تستطيع الماء همم الطالب ان ياخذ
هذه الافكار وينمي الافكار وينقلها من
مرحله الفكره الى مرحله الابداع حاله
التصنيع كل هذه مبثوثه في مراحل التعليم
بحيث انه ذات الملكيه الفكريه تكون قدمت
الشراء في جميع المراحل التعليميه وفي
جميع المواد التعليميه يكون اثرها
التراكمي على طريقه الطالب
الاحترام ذاته وقدره على ان يكون
قدره عاليه جدا عندما ينافس
حاله يمكن همم
موازيه للمعلم اللي قدم مثل هذه الموضوعات
والمواد وهذه المضامين هل لديكم اي برامج
لتطوير المعلمين ايضا اللي طرق تعليم
الملكيه الفكريه والتفاعل معه بشكل صحيح
يعني احنا بالفعل بدانا في تدريب عدد كبير
جدا من المعلمين فوق بعض المجادل متعلقه
الفكريه خرجنا الدفع الاولى ايضا من معلمي
الملكيه الفكريه القادرين على تدمير في
مسارات الملكيه الفكريه تم تطوير مع
المنظمه العالميه الملكيه الفكريه برامج
متخصصه للمملكه في مسارات المرتبطه
توافق مع الانظمه المعمول بها في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايضا ممكن تم تطوير
اكاديميه الملكيه الفكريه في الهيئه
السعوديه والكيه الفكريه يضع معاها ان هذه
الاكاديميه تقدم الدعم والمسانده للمعلمين
وايضا لمطور المناهج التعليم
هي كان همم فكره من عندكم انتم ولا في
دراسات لدول اخرى كانت تستفيد من مثل هذا
الناس او النادي المنهجيه في في الثاني
سريع
والحقيقه يعني المملكه من اوائل الدول
التي ساعدت الى البث مواضيع وكيل فكري في
جميع المناهج التعليميه نعم هناك
سنغافوره وفي بعض الاخرى بالاضافه الى
المنظمه العالميه تدعم مثل هذه التوجهات
والمملكه الحمد من اوائل الدول التي ساعد
الى بث المناهج
الدراسيه معينه ولا بشكل عام
ان شاء الله ينعكس حلو عليك
شكرا جزيلا لك الرئيس تنفيذ السعوديه
للملكيه الفكريه الدكتور عبد العزيز
السعوديه دشنت النيابه العامه وحده تعنى
بشؤون الطفل التي تتبع او ستتبع نظامين
الوحده الى التمكين الاطفال من الحصول على
كافه الحقوق التي كفلها نظام بالسعوديه مع
حكمتي وتنظيم تطبيق
اجتماعيه امنه
تفاصيل اكثر حول هذه الوحدات
قوانين حمايه الاطفال في السعوديه مع
زميله العنود العبدلي
حقوقهم في السعوديه حيث دشنت النيابه
العامه وحده شؤون الطفل تتبع لنيابه
الاسره والاحداث وتهدف الوحده الجديده الى
مراعاه مصالح الاطفال وحكمت الاجراءات
النظاميه في القضايا التي يكون الطفل احد
ضحاياها اضافه الى التحقق من الاجراءات
الاجتماعيه والرعائيه التي يحظى بها
الاطفال النائب العام سعود المعجب اكد على
التزام النيابه العامه بالمحافظه على
الاسر واستقرارها وحمايه الطفوله وتوفير
بيئه امنه اللحام وكانت السعوديه وقد
اطلقت في نهايه العام 2014 نظام حمايه
الطفل ونصف النظام على حظه استغلال
الاطفال في اي ممارسات غير مشروعه مثل
التسول كما يحضروا تشغيل الطفل قبل بلوغه
سن الخامسه او الخامسه عشره وتكليفه
باعمال قد تضر بسلامته او بص البدنيه او
النفسيه الماده الثانيه عشر من نظام حمايه
الطفل نصت على حظر اي محتوى موجه للاطفال
يخاطب الغريزه او يثيرها للخروج عن الاداب
العامه الانشطه الترفيهيه ليست متاحه بشكل
كامل للاطفال حيث نص نظام حمايه الطفل في
السعوديه على منع مشاركه الطفل في
النشاطات الترفيهيه التي تعرض سلامته او
صحته للخطر
الرابعه تواكب مشروع تطوير قلعه عارف
التاريخيه في حائل يعود عمرها الى اكثر من
مصري نحو التطبيع العلاقات واردوغان يؤكد
على علاقاتنا وسام على القاهره في
المستقبل
مشروع سعوديين موضوعات الملكيه الفكريه في
جميع العالم
وحده جديده لشؤون الاطفال في النيابه
العامه السعوديه ضوابط طول الرعايه
والحمايه والترفيه
الرابعه تواكبوا مشروع تطوير قلعه عارف
التاريخيه في حائل التي يعود عمرها الى
اكثر من 200 عام
وفي ثاني ايام كاس العالم 2022 في قطر
ايران تواجهه الانجليزي والسنغال تلتقي
هولندا
اهلا بكم من جديد اكملت امانه منطقه حائل
في شمال السعوديه مشروع التطوير المنطقه
المجاوره لقلعه عرفه التاريخيه التي يعود
عمرها الى ما يزيد وعلى 200 عاما المشروع
المعلن عنه يحتوي على 10,000 متر مربع من
المسطحات الخضراء في محيط القلعه
التاريخيه بالاضافه الى ما يزيد على 500
شجره باختلاف انواعها فضلا عن ممرات
للمشاه يصل طولها الى 900 متر كما يضم
المشروع 12 من فدا للبيع
ومن قلعه عرفه في حائل ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سالم الراجح حياك الله سالم عرفنا
اكثر على هذه القناه
نعم نقف الان في في المنطقه المحيطه بقلعه
عريف تحديدا في هذا المشروع بالبدايه خالد
دعنا نتعرف على القيمه التاريخيه لهذه
القلعه التي بنيت قبل ما يقارب 250 عام
على اعلى احد الجبال في وسط منطقه حائل
بنيت كقلعه عسكريه تشرف على كافه المناطق
المحيطه بمدينه حائل بعد ذلك مع مرور
الزمن تحديدا في الزمن الحالي اصبحت احد
المواقع واحد اهم المواقع التاريخيه
والسياحيه في المنطقه هي مفتوحه بشكل
يوميا للزوار وتشرف عليها الهيئه العامه
للتراث هذا في ما يخص القلعه اما عن مشروع
تطوير المنطقه المحيطه بقلعه عارف الذي
شارف على النهايه ومن المتوقع ان يتم
تدشينه همم قريبا هذا المشروع عملت عليه
وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه منذ عده
سنوات بدايه من نزع ملكيات المناطق حيطه
بهذه القلعه كانت هناك بعض الاملاك الخاصه
في المناطق المحيطه لان هذا المشروع هو من
جميع الاتجاهات حول القلعه تم نزع ما
يقارب 21 عقارا بقيمه 60 مليون ريال بعد
ذلك بدا العمل الميداني على تطوير هذه
المنطقه كما نشاهد الموقع يحتضن مجموعه من
الساحات العامه والمماشي يحتضن 10,000 متر
مربع من المسطحات الخضراء بالاضافه الى 40
موقع همم الجلوس و12 منفذ للبيع سيتم
تسليمه للمستثمرين لتوفير الخدمات
الاساسيه خالد الموقع يحتضر 900 متر من
مواقع المخصصه للمشي اذا ما تحدثنا عن
المواقع على المخصصه للمشي فان حائل هي
احوج من غيرها في هذا الموضوع لعده اسباب
الاحصائيات التي تنشرها العامه للاحصاء
اظهرت ان نسبه مما المشي في منطقه حائل
سواء في عام 2019 او حتى في العام الماضي
عام 2021 كانت هائل هي اقل المدن السعوديه
في ممارسه المشي لذلك همم من الممكن ان
تعزز مثل هذه المواقع المخصصه للمشاهده
سواء في المواقع المركزيه مثل قلعه عارف
او حتى داخل الاحياء من الممكن ان تعزز
همم السكان او الاهالي على ممارسه همم
المشي همم وتقليل نسب السمنه حسب نظرته
الاحصائيات التي تنشرها وزاره الصحه فيما
يتعلق على هذا او في هذا المشروع من
المتوقع ان يتم تجهينه بشكل رسمي بحضور
وزير الشؤون البلديه والقرويه والاسكان
خلال الاسابيع القليله همم همم القادمه
هذا محتوى او هذه ابرز محتويات مشروع
تطوير المنطقه المحيطه بقلعه عارف في
منطقه حائل خالد في حائل كيف اوضاعك مع
الاهل والاخوان عساك مستمتع وكيف الاجواء
اكيد مستمتع خالد خصوصا اذا النشره
ما شفنا الشمس الا امس ولا الاسبوع الماضي
واللي قبل كان كله غيوم وضباب
درجه الحراره اليوم يقولون منخفضه بشكل
كبير ولا لا مقارنه بعض المناطق المملكه
الاجواء تحديدا في الفتره في فتره
النهاريه اجواء ممتازه يعني ما بين 18 الى
20 درجه مئويه في المساء تحديدا في ساعات
الصباح الاولى تكون درجه الحراره ابرد
يعني تصل الى اقل من 15 درجه مئويه ولكن
البارد في الفتره القادمه بالتاكيد سيكون
اكثر تحديدا في نهايه السنه وبدايه السنه
الميلاديه القادمه
الراغبين في حضور مباريات بطوله كاس
العالم 2022
وقدمت الجوازات السعوديه استعدادها
لاستقبال المشجعين على مدارس الساعه من
خلال تجهيز صاله خاصه وسطت توقعات بازدياد
حركه المسافرين في المنفذ قبيله مباراه
المنتخب السعودي غدا امام الارجنتين
من منفذ سلوى الحدودي مع قطر ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي اهلا عبد
المحسن مشاهداتك في المنفذ حتى الان وكيف
شايف الاستعدادات وعدد الجمهور يعني ايضا
الذي يمر
عدد كبير جدا خالد منذ الصباح كنا
متواجدين في مناطق مختلفه في المحيط هذا
المنفذ في تحديدا في منطقه همم حافلات
التردديه عدد كبير من المشجعين لا نتحدث
فقط عن مشجعين المنتخب السعودي او حتى
السعوديه الراغبين بحضور كاس العالم في
قطر انما كذلك
المشجعين من الدول الاخرى في الصباح اليوم
قبل مباراه منتخب همم انجلترا الجاريه
الان كان هناك ازدحام كثيف من قبل
الانجليزي الذين رغبوا او تفضلوا المكوث
في السعوديه والدخول عبر منفذ سلوى ليوم
واحد حضور مباراه والعوده الى السعوديه
مجددا عبر همم هذا المنفذ الذي تقدم فيه
الخدمات ويتم استقبال في المشجعين على
مدار الساعه كم تشاهد في الخلف ونحن
سنتحدث الان مع الرائد ناصر العتيبي وهو
متحدث الرسمي للجوازات رائد ناصر اليوم
للمش هذه همم الصاله وكاننا اشبه ما يكون
في مطار ولسنا في منفذ بري بحسب الصوره
التي نشاهدها في الخلف مرحبا بكم في
جوازات منفذ سلوى والتي تعمل منذ وقت مبكر
على مدار 24 ساعه لنهائي كافه اجراءات
كافه اجراءات المواطنين والمقيمين وايضا
الزائرين الراغبين بالسفر لحضور فعاليات
العالم كما تشاهد حاليا يتم الان اجراءات
باص من المسافرين في الصدر المخصصه لحفلات
التردديه عددهم 22 42 راكبا عفوا سيتم
هجرات من خلال مده زمنيه وجيزه جدا
الصلاه مميزاتها عدد الموظفين هل تعمل على
مدار الساعه كيف هي ايضا استعداداتكم
للايام القادمه بس يكون هنالك عدد اكبر من
ذلك بكثير هذه صاله تم التدشينها بالتعاون
مع الهيئه العامه للزكاه والضريبه والجمال
عليك تعمل الان كيف الطاقه الاستيعابيه
كما تشاهد همم ايضا هناك مسارات مخصصه
للمركبات يتم منها من خلالها انها اجراءات
كافه المس سواء سيارات القطريه اول
السيارات السعوديه ايضا الذين لديهم
الاشتراضات اللازمه من قبل السلطات
القطريه لحضور فعاليات كاس العالم اهم
الاشترطات في المديريه العامه للجوازات
على الراغبين الذين نعمل حاليا على
تطبيقها في جوازات منفذ سلوى وجميع منافذ
المملكه المؤديه الى دوله قطر الشقيقه
وجود جواز سفر لا تقل عن صلاحيه عن ثلاثه
اشهر للمواطنين السعوديين والمواطنين دول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي ايضا الاعتقل صلاحيه
عن سته اشهر لجميع الدول ومن اهم
الاشتراطات الواجب تركيزها على المواطنين
السعوديين ايضا همم السفر بجواز السفر حيث
الهويه الوطنيه خلال الفتره الحاليه والى
23 ديسمبر لا تمكن حاملها من السفر الى
دوله قطر الشرقيه
قبل قليل واحد من التقنيات الجديده لديكم
في الجوازات ده ممكن تحدثنا عنها
كاميرا التوثيق التي يرتديها موظف
الجوازات وتقوم بتوثيق الحاله التفاعليه
ما بين موظف الجوازات والمراجع والمسافر
لتجويد الخدمه وتقديم اجمل اجود الخدمات
على مستوى عالي من قبل الجوازات شكرا لكم
تشاهد هذه القاع عامه ان يدخل عدد كبير من
المشجعين تحدث عن 30 شخص في لحظه واحده
حتى يخرجوا بشكل سريع جدا بعد ذلك تاتي
الحافله التي تليها في عمليه وسلسله
متواصله همم مستمره همم لا تنتهي عند هذا
همم
تستمر حتى منفذ ابو سمره همم القطري حيث
هنالك تعاون ما بين السعوديه وقطر لتسهيل
هذه العمليه بشكل كبير على المشجعين
واختصار الوقت بشكل اكبر ليحظه المباريات
باسرع وقت ممكن وان يصلوا الى الملاعب في
همم في وقت مناسب خالد شكرا لك عبد المحسن
الحربي
والحدود مع قطر
تتكون الفصول والمواسم نتيجه حركه السحب
وحركه النجوم تقويم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للسحب حركه تبعا لحركه الرياح الدافعه لها
وللنجوم حركه تبعا لدوران الارض حول نفسها
ودورانها حول الشمس ونتيجه لهذا تتكون
الفصول والمواسم وهذه الفصول سحبها لها
اتجاه يا غربيه يا شرقيه الغربيه ماطره
الشرقيه عابره والعابره تكون حركتها بطيئه
ومنفرشه وكاتمه للاجواء وهذا يكون في عز
القيض وحب اذكركم مهنا لنا حركه تبعا
لحركه الايام لنا دع الايام تفعل ما
تشاءوا وطب نفس اذا حكم القضاء ولا تجزع
لحادثه الليالي فما لحوادث الدنيا
وقائع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دخولي موسم الوسم من شهر اكتوبر وطالع
تبدا تاتين السحب من الجهه الغربيه
كتخريجات بحريه من البحر الاحمر او
مستورده من هضبه البحيرات هو البحر الابيض
المتوسط ومع دخول مربعانيه البيض تبدا
تاتينا من الجهه الشرقيه كتخريجات بحريه
من الخليج العربي او مستورده من بحر العرب
وما بين الصيف والشتاء تكون متخلخله في
حركتها وليس لها وجه وما الحزن في وجه
الفتاه شرفا له اذا لم يكن في فعله
والخلائقي
[موسيقى]
نحو اربعه واربعين
300 اخرون في زلزال ضرب جزيره جاوا
العاصمه الاندونيسيه جاكرتا وبحسب مسؤول
الحكوميه فان الزلزال بلغت شدته 5.6 من 10
درجات على مقياس ريختر كان مركزه اقليم
الغربي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الختان
يؤكد على علاقات اوسع مع القاهره في
المستقبل
مشروع عن السعوديه لادراج الموضوعات
الملكيه الفكريه في جميع مراحل التعليم
العام
وحده جديده لشؤون الاطفال في نيابه العامه
السعوديه ضوابط للرعايه والحمايه والترفيه
ورابعه تركب مشروع التطوير قلعه عرفه
التاريخيه في حائل التي يعود عمرها الى
اكثر من 200 عام
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]